E aí
[Música]
e antes de recitar o poema eu vou ler
uma breve passagem pelo discurso de
Malala ao receber o prêmio Nobel da Paz
e principalmente para o grupo
maravilhoso destes jovens que acabaram
Denis oferecer estes pensamentos e
é muito me orgulho de ter sido a
primeira partes turno a primeira
paquistanesa e a primeira adolescente
receber este prémio e tenho a certeza
absoluta de ser também a primeira pessoa
a receber um Nobel da Paz que ainda
discute com os seus irmãos mais novos
e eu quero que aparece Espalhe por todos
os cantos mas os meus irmãos e eu ainda
estamos a trabalhar nisso palavra uma
Lala significa e lotada triste mas
tentando Embu ir um pouco alegria ela o
meu avô iria sempre chamar-me de Malala
a rapariga mais feliz do mundo e hoje
estou muito feliz de estarmos aqui
reunidos por uma causa tão importante
educação passou de um direito é um crime
mas como mudança repentina no meu mundo
as minhas prioridades também se
modificaram eu tinha duas opções a
primeira era permanecer Calado e esperar
por ser assassinada a segunda era gay a
voz e em seguida ser assassinada eu
escolhi a segunda eu decidi erguer a voz
os terroristas tentaram de termos e
atacaram a minha as minhas amigas e Nove
de outubro de 2012 mas as suas balas não
podiam ver nascer nós sobrevivemos e
desde aquele dia as nossas vozes só se
fizeram erguer mais altas encontra
minhas
É porque ela seja a única mas
principalmente porque não é embora Na
aparência ou seja uma menina uma pessoa
com 1,57 de altura contando com os
saldos saldos eu não sou uma voz
solitária eu sou muitas
Olá eu sou aqueles 66 milhões de meninas
como eu disse no ano passado nas Nações
Unidas uma criança um professor uma
caneta e um livro podem mudar o mundo
alguns dirão que está em praticável
muito caro muito difícil ou mesmo
impossível mas é hora de pensar grande
queridos irmãos e irmãs o chamado mundo
dos adultos pode compreender isso mas
nós as crianças não porque os países a
que chamamos fortes são tão poderosos em
criar guerras mas são tão fracos em
trazer a paz o que fornecer armas então
fácil mas doar livros é tão difícil
porque fabricar tantos é tão fácil mas
construir escolas é tão difícil apela às
crianças como eu levantar em todo o
mundo seja esta última vez que o menino
ou uma menina desperdice a sua infância
uma fábrica seja esta a última vez que
uma menina seja obrigada a casar-se na
infância seja este sal
o que uma criança inocente perde a vida
na guerra seja esta a última vez que uma
sala de aula permaneça dizia que seja
esta última vez que se diga a uma menina
que a educação é um crime não direito
o que conhecemos nós encerrar essa
situação sejamos nós a dar o Finn isto
que conhecemos a construir um futuro
melhor aqui agora obrigada o discurso
chamado falei os arrozais feito durante
a cerimônia de entrega do prêmio Nobel
em Oslo é o Nobel da Paz a Dez de
Dezembro 2014 e agora vamos a poesia a
poesia é uma arma carregada de futuro
e quando já Nada se espera de
pessoalmente exaltante mas se palpite
esse continua para cada consciência
geralmente existindo cegamente firmando
como um curso que lateja nas trevas
quando se olham diferente os Claros
olhos vertiginosos da Morte dizem as
verdades as bárbaras terríveis amorosos
crueldade dizem seus poemas que dilatam
os pulmões de quantos asfixiadas podem
ser pedem ritmo pedem lei para o que
sentem se vo
e com a velocidade me sinto com raio do
prodígio Como Mágica evidência converse
real no idêntico a si mesmo
a poesia para o pobre poesia necessária
como o pão de cada dia como arco
exigimos exigimos três vezes por minuto
para ser e enquanto somos dizer um sim
que glorifica Porque vivemos de vez em
quando porque mal os deixam dizer que
somos quem somos nossos cantos não podem
Sem Pecado ser um ornamento estamos a
tocar o fundo maldigo a poesia Concebida
como um luxo cultural os neutrais
levando as mãos desinteresse o invadem
maldigo a poesia de quem não toma
partido até manchar
eu faço minhas as faltas sinto em mim
quando sofrem o cantor arrepiar Canto
Canto e a cantar para além das minhas
mágoas pessoais e players
a feira de árvores vida provocar novos
dados e cálculo por isso com técnica que
venço sinto-me o engenheiro do verso em
um operário que com quantos outros
trabalhar Espanha nos seus ossos assim é
minha poesia poesia ferramenta e ao
mesmo tempo pulsação do ânimo e 5
e assim é arma carregada de futuro
expansivo com que aponta ao peito
e não é uma poesia gota-a-gota pensada
e nem um belo produto
e nem um belo fruto perfeito é algo como
ar que todos respiramos é um tanto e diz
fundo dentro e vamos são palavras que
todos repetimos sentindo como nossas e
voam são mais e o que elas dizem são
mais necessário
Oi suy nome
já estão no céu e na terra são as
Gabriel Celaya
eu ia agora para terminar
e na surdez de um vazio cósmico e sem
hesitação ela segue girando sobre si
o sorvete
a parte da sua descoberta no serpentear
do teu olhar nos jogar o teu olhar e
encontras um sentido sobre como saciar
dos seus e vontades e de a ver tocar e
sentir e alcançar Campos e Segredos
usados ademais como os mortais nos
caminhos perdidos que levam habitantes
distantes avulsa ao abrigo das sombras
dos arvoredos vozes quentes plenas de
células de estrelas avisa as calmas
exóticas que queimam arrepiam a tua pele
capazes de sentir teus sussurros e
silêncios e anseios
é o fim da noite
e após a pausa do Resgate antes de todas
as palavras e pontuações Se arrumarem os
seus lugares levantas o teu olhar
sorrindo rumo às estrelas e ele te
encontras em ti
o Norberto Amaral
E aí
[Música]